we'll start the show in just a second
but first i want to tell you about
today's
sponsors nebia is a revolutionary shower
head that saves you money by using 45
percent less water but with a stream of
water that's way more powerful
than what you get with other shower
heads to get fifteen percent off
go to nebia.com pacman and use the code
pacman
magic spoon is the cereal that tastes
exactly like the delicious cereals from
your childhood except it has no sugar
tons of protein and only three net carbs
so it's perfect for a keto diet
to get free shipping go to
magicspoon.com
pacman and use the code pacman blinkist
is the app that helps you become a more
well-rounded
person by letting you read or listen to
an entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman
so donald trump's casual musings about
the potential to declare martial law
reportedly have the military on red
alert but not on red alert to
participate in
enforcing the martial law in fact it's
quite the opposite the military
is not on red alert preparing to enforce
martial law which is a suspension of
civil law
in lieu of military justice becoming the
law of the land
the military is on red alert not because
they want to be prepared to help trump
they want to be prepared in case
protesters go so crazy
if trump tries to install martial law
that the military might be required to
help quell
violence and restore order multiple
officers who spoke to newsweek
of course on the condition of anonymity
agree
that there's no chance whatsoever that
the military would actually try to
help donald trump overturn the results
or enforce the martial
law that trump is supposedly musing and
wondering about
but what the military officers are
worried about
is that by trying to push martial law if
trump were to do it
that the military could end up getting
sucked into having to clean up the mess
that donald trump
might make and the thought is that
donald trump could
inadvertently or deliberately rally
so-called private militias and pro-trump
paramilitary types
and the military could end up being
needed to help protect
from those groups now the consensus is
that there's no
group or contingent or cabal of military
officers that would actually go with
donald trump's idea
but the military could end up needing to
come to the defense of the people
depending on what happens and notably
the contingency planning is happening
completely out of sight of the white
house
and the known trump loyalists at the
pentagon
because the military recognizes that if
you involve the white house or trump
loyalists in the pentagon
in and let them know that you're
planning in this way they may
actually try to interfere with what
you're doing or even notify donald trump
and along those lines the other crazy
aspect of this
is that top military brass understand
that if they publicly said we would
never support
any attempt at martial law because trump
thinks he
really won when he lost um they
recognized that if they
went public with their names it could
make trump go absolutely crazy
and make him more likely to try this
stuff so the reporting is that the
military officer community is just kind
of laying low
contingency planning out of sight but
not attaching their names to any
specific
uh public rebukes of donald trump's
martial law musings and and to be frank
i understand that and the question comes
up of whether donald trump
absent support from the military
would try to pull in blackwater type
mercenary groups or
others which would be just a new level
of insanity and hopefully it will never
come to that
uh donald trump just went to florida
for the holiday and there's the idea
that
trump may never even come back to
washington dc like he may just stay in
florida
this will all fade away and be nothing
or not we don't know
um i've actually already left the
country i've i've not even been in the
u.s for a bit i'm not going to be back
until
after the inauguration the show will
look the same i've i've been mentioning
you know multiple studios lately nothing
will change when we get back from new
year's break
but i'm beating the rush and i'm just
going to be elsewhere for the next
period of time
why chance it you know that that's my
approach and then just one last thing
this is also part of why the electoral
college should really be gotten rid of
biden won by about eight million votes
but
about a hundred thousand votes in a few
swing states
were the margin that provided the
electoral victory
the electoral victory seems much more
plausibly
overturnable when it comes down to a
hundred thousand votes in a handful of
states
whereas how do you even plausibly claim
to try to circumvent
an 8 million vote loss
just another signal about the the
importance of continuing to fight
to get rid of the electoral college and
that's even a separate issue then the
electoral college helps republican
presidents yes it does
but regardless of that uh there are
other reasons
to get rid of it so on tuesday donald
trump did this video screed where he had
sort of like conflicting and confused
reasons
for which he was threatening to veto the
second coronavirus stimulus package
on wednesday he did veto that package
and one of the things donald trump said
he wanted
is a two thousand dollar stimulus check
rather than a six hundred dollar
stimulus check now
very conveniently many democrats
including our friend ro khanna
have been talking about two thousand
dollars per person for a while
and as soon as donald trump said i want
two grand many democrats said great
let's work together on it we're ready to
do it but the republican party has
blocked an attempt democrats did move
to increase the size of the checks when
trump said let's do two thousand
and um it is not going to happen because
yesterday house republicans blocked
the attempt by democrats to do two
thousand dollar
payments and now we are simply waiting
on
whether the house will vote to override
trump's veto on monday
and whether if that happens the senate
will vote to override
trump's veto on tuesday um
but it is uh it's just not going
anywhere the republican party has been
arguing for less and less
money and uh the house tried to pass
two thousand dollar payments on uh
christmas eve day
so yesterday during the day they had a
brief meeting
of the house where um democrats
tried to approve two thousand dollar
payments by unanimous consent which
means any one lawmaker can block it it's
not
a 50 plus or super majority or whatever
it is simply um any one republican any
one lawmaker can block it
uh congressman steny hoyer democrat
offered the proposal from the floor
and it was blocked by house minority
leader
kevin mccarthy and that is it
uh so we that there's really no
expectation at this point that that is
going to happen
um under trump's watch house speaker
nancy pelosi
said that on monday she will do a
recorded vote
on the two thousand dollar payments but
i mean it's
not going to make any difference at this
point in time democrats continue to tell
trump just sign the bill
and um let's uh
i mean listen one of the other problems
here is why
is the government funding bill part of
the same vote
as the coveted stimulus bill we know why
this is a common thing that's done
in in congress the idea is if you're
against a bunch of stuff one party wants
to do
you say let's join this vote with the
stuff we want to do
you do one vote for both bills and then
20 years later much like we've seen
happen with bernie and joe biden and
others when you're asked
why did you vote in favor of bill a and
you say listen
i wasn't really in favor of bill a i was
in favor of bill b
but our colleagues on the other side
said the only way they would support it
is if we wrapped it up with bill a
i found it so important to get the
people six hundred dollars instead of
zero
that i conceded i said i'll give them
bill a because they're giving me bill b
which i think is the the right bill for
for helping people this is politics this
is how it always works it's disgusting
there's no
actual reason that you couldn't have one
vote on covet stimulus
and then separately one vote on uh
government funding but that is the way
that they have done it
and um one of the interesting sort of
little details is we talked yesterday
about how donald trump has turned
on basically everybody around him mike
pence
uh mike pompeo he's he believes none of
them are supporting him in his
bid to overturn the election results
mitch mcconnell's also on that list and
mitch mcconnell has been against more
stimulus for months and when it's
a conversation about stimulus he wants
the smallest possible stimulus
since trump suggested the two thousand
dollar payments
mitch mcconnell has been silent uh
about the demand for the two thousand
dollar
payments um and it is just
you know the who really loses here it's
the people
right and this is why when we talk about
political posturing by either side
when we talk about um
all of these different public moves that
do
nothing to actually get help to people
to be any closer to a reality
um we we have to remember that a bunch
of this stuff
is almost almost as bad
on the democratic side as the republican
side
so we'll see what happens monday with
the house vote on overriding trump's
veto
we'll see what happens tuesday
conditionally with the senate voting to
override that same veto
and maybe by mid-january
payments could be going to people it
will take uh a couple at least a couple
of weeks it is believed
once if and when this is approved for
money to get into anybody's hands so
certainly
2021 not this is not going to be 2020
money
in the best case uh at all we've got a
great program for you today we will be
off all of next week the show will be
off next week just reminding everybody
no show next week and then we will be
back with you in the new year but we
still have
plenty going on today remember that
on a january 1st 1121
we have a huge membership special going
on
if you want to be notified about it just
get on my newsletter at davidpakman.com
um it is it this is a the type of
membership special
people have never even heard of before
nevermind seen
all right so get on that mailing list at
davidpakman.com quick break
much more the david pakman show at
davidpakman.com
[Music]
one of our sponsors today is nebia the
creator of the world's most
innovative shower head it uses only
about
half the water that other shower heads
do saving you money helping the
environment
but it's actually a lot more powerful
than other shower heads on the market it
has twice the coverage of other shower
heads
the water sprays with a ton of pressure
i've been using it in my bathroom at
home
i love it only took a few minutes to set
up really easy and it's been a totally
different experience
than any other shower head i've used i
can get in and out of the shower way
quicker now
because of how powerful it is it only
takes a few seconds to get
completely rinsed off so i was actually
amazed
that it's only using about half as much
water
nebia also offers a number of shower
accessories like shelves and curtains
which match
perfectly with the design of the shower
head the shower head starts at just
199 but the first hundred people to go
to nebia.com
pacman and use code pacman will get 15
off all nebia products
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
remember that the number one way to
support the david pakman show you all
know it it's a membership at
joinedpakman.com
and you can use the coupon code at least
if and until joe biden makes these codes
illegal you can use the coupon code
fresh start
to get a massive discount
off of a membership joinpacman.com is
the place to do it
let's go to the phones for the absolute
last final time
of 2020 on discord
davidpakman.com slash discord
let's first go to kate in ohio
kate in ohio what is going on
uh not much david how are you doing i'm
doing well
cool so uh
do i ask you a question that would be a
great next step yeah let's do it
uh so do you think it's uh politically
important to eventually abolish the uh
the electoral college as really it's the
only way republicans can
uh win the elections nowadays as their
ideas are
generally becoming less popular yes i do
i do think so and we've talked before
about the paths to doing it
um i don't i don't really see any path
you can never say never i don't see any
path anytime soon to doing it
via constitutional amendment because
there are so many
red states that know that their
candidates have won
solely because we have an electoral
college system instead of a popular vote
system
so if it's going to happen even
relatively soon
i believe it would be through something
like the national popular vote
interstate compact
npvic i've talked about that before but
yes i i think
uh if the now it is true
what republicans say that if we had a
national popular vote
they would run elections differently and
trump has said that
but regardless i think it would be a
massive uphill battle for the republican
party to climb
okay cool
all right thanks very much kate i
appreciate it great to hear uh from
kate from ohio let's go um
next to manraj
from chicago did i get that name right
uh yeah you got that name right good job
on it and i just want to say love the
show you know
been a been a member and very excited to
uh thank you
get back to your question uh so i i'm
just gonna ask you a quick
two-part question so the first is you
know what kind of
pressure can leftists and progressives
expect to
uh you have over the policy uh policy
agenda of a biden administration if we
you know i don't think it's gonna happen
but let's say we get the 50
senators and we get the two in uh
georgia if that does happen what kind of
uh i guess influence we can exert on
that and then the you know just follow
up to that
uh with florida and especially you know
the 15
minimum wage uh law that passed through
a direct ballot initiative
do you see that as more winning strategy
to push for those kind of initiatives
uh well so there's a couple different
things there let's first talk about the
pressure that
that the democrats could put on joe
biden
if democrats take the senate because
democrats get the two seats in georgia
it will be 50 50 meaning democrats
meaning joe biden anything he wants to
get done he will likely need
every single democratic senator now if
you lose one like joe manchin as we talk
about
then you'll need a republican senator so
the point is
joe biden if he has a 50-50 senate with
kamala as the tie-breaking vote he can't
afford to lose a single democrat to get
big things done
meaning that is the leverage that the
more progressive democrats in the senate
can say
you need every single one of our votes
to do
a you've got to work with us on b that's
the leverage
that that leverage doesn't exist if
democrats don't win the two georgia
senate races so
is is that part is that part clear yeah
yeah and you know i think i always saw
it the other way where the joe manchins
have the leverage to pull their votes
but
i guess i didn't realize that hey you
know progressive senators
you know the liz warrens and whatnot
they have that same leverage anybody
could
exactly now in terms of direct ballot
initiatives
i love direct ballot initiatives but
direct ballot initiatives happen
at the municipal and state level so it's
we're talking about
different things altogether the direct
ballot initiative is not going to be a
replacement
to the house and senate passing
something and it being signed into law
by joe biden
in most cases there are things you could
say listen if you do these in all 50
states
the effect will be just as if joe biden
got it done through the house and senate
but in practice i can't think of
anything that would get through all 50
states so so
it's just it's a different tool for
different projects
okay yeah no that's a very good good
explanation for it and uh yeah just love
your show and uh
yeah doing great work so how cold is it
in chicago these days
you know it's not too bad it's not too
bad i guess my gauge of it is how much
uh you know my dog likes to be outside
and right now he hasn't
he's uh let's just say i'm sick of the
walk before he is though
yeah i mean even here in new york city
we've had some uh
close to close to 60 degree days so it's
uh it's quite a scene
all right my friend i appreciate the
call i mean it's probably bad it
probably relates to climate change but
it's certainly
pleasant if uh if nothing else let's go
next
to uh why don't we go
oh i don't know there's just so many
people let's go to christopher from
houston texas
to christopher from houston what's going
on
you're the voice is coming through very
oddly but i can hear you
okay yeah i'm talking in my uh my ford
fusion right now so
uh ford fusion now i believe ford fusion
is one of the latest vehicles that
is going from being available in a stick
shift to automatic only is that
is that correct uh i i i couldn't tell
you i'm not totally sure
beautiful i love it all right so uh
i'm a i'm a physical therapist uh a
doctor of physical therapy
and i'm uh i do home health
so you know i i go to people's houses
and you know help them out in the home
after they've
gone home from the hospital yep and i
guess i just wanted to kind of give kind
of a
ground report of what it's like in rural
texas uh
before the election like every other
house you know
fox news is on full blast all the time
you know and then now we're at like 50
50 newsmax and fox news being on
all the time so that's uh now let me ask
you this this is this is so
this is such a dumb question in the
sense that i should know this but
um i only consume any of this stuff
online
is newsmax on regular cable for people
or or is it only on sat like how do you
i'm only familiar with getting newsmax
on the computer
is it part of people's cable packages
down there
i i really have no idea maybe they're
they're savvy and then i got you know
some uh
you know internet tv going on but so i'm
not exactly sure
i just noticed that that you know
they're on their tvs while i'm
you know trying to do the therapy and i
have to tell them to mute the tv because
i can't
hear my own hear myself talk and have um
have any of the people that you're
you're working with do they let slip
bonkers conspiracy theories that they
would have gotten from newsmax
oh oh uh absolutely like like daily so i
i i kind of act undercover while i'm
working with them you know
they be like oh yeah that's crazy like
totally the democrats
are you know basically bought off by
china and everything blah blah blah
oh you play you play along in other
words yeah
yeah yeah because you know it it if they
don't uh
agree with me it's harder for me to you
know work with them do my therapy and
all that i understand that
it's kind of interesting to see the
range of
uh opinions out here in rural texas so
all right well listen uh i i don't envy
you and um
keep up the good work and let's let's
hope things improve
all right thanks i love the show all
right thanks very much wow yeah that
sounds that sounds uh pretty
pretty bonkers um why don't we go
next to um oh this is interesting
let's go to maria from colombia
but calling from germany do i have that
right maria
yes you're right i love it what now
you i don't know if you've heard this
caller pedro from colombia
who clearly is is not from colombia what
part of colombia are you actually from
i'm from bogota okay see that's that's a
clear
answer uh and so i believe you
okay good that's an easy one but yeah
definitely
pedro doesn't have a colombian accent no
not at all
um okay good oh by the way i am watching
a you might find this interesting maria
i have started watching a netflix series
called perdida which takes place
mostly in colombia and um
it's it's quite good i have not heard of
it but i'm going to
watch it yeah definitely but enough
about me what's on your mind today
um on my mind well uh i have family
issues trying to communicate with them
and i remember that once you said that
for example to talk about uh
controversial issues like abortion
it's good to have like a common ground
like what everyone should agree on
and for example yeah everyone should
agree on having less
abortions even if you're pro-choice or
if you're pro-life
and that has helped me a lot and i was
wondering whether you have another topic
in mind that it's controversial
but that we can find a common ground
maybe yeah i don't know
i mean there's there's so many it would
be better if you had a topic that you're
looking to discuss and we could think
about the best way to do it is there a
particular topic that is a problem right
now
well regarding cobit i think well right
now
my family right now especially my
grandfather he's suffering now from
uh kovid and his saturation levels are
very low and it feels like yeah
i'm hopeless i don't know i would i wish
i could communicate with them
a lot better but i just yeah it's
complicated
but is it that you're so your family
they're not taking the virus seriously
or they believe it's a hoax or what it
what's the disagreement
um they believe at the beginning they
thought it was
a hoax now one of my uncles he
got infected and he was on a ventilator
for 86 days
he survived yes but still it seemed like
uh well actually i guess it everything
starts with
a lack of trust on the health care
workers i think
that's the main issue and um you know
what's interesting about that here's the
opportunity right here's the opportunity
if if your family doesn't trust
the health care workers the best way to
avoid
having to interact with them is not to
get the virus so where i
where i might approach this is hey you
know what
nobody wants to have to deal with
healthcare workers if you don't have to
so that should be extra incentive to
stay healthy so we don't end up needing
healthcare workers to do anything for us
i would probably think of that as the
entry point
yeah i i agree i agree it sounds yeah
sounds
very reasonable yeah yeah but now unless
to understand
you're the family that you're referring
to they're in germany or they're in
colombia or they're somewhere else
uh well my my uh grandfather and my
aunts they're in southern california
so yeah okay god it's all over the place
all right well listen that sounds tough
but that's that's my thought maria
yeah thanks thanks i really like your
show i appreciate
uh your opinion yeah thank you so much
oh is there someone else there now yes
my boyfriend
oh okay uh is he colombian
yes oh he is oh all right well listen
you are the
real colombian callers and you are
replacing
uh pedro from colombia so
congratulations
thanks all right take care okay let's
take a very quick break
but if you're holding don't hang up i
mean hang up if you want to but
i you have an opportunity to speak with
me if you keep holding because we'll go
right back to the phones
momentarily the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
one of our sponsors today is magic spoon
the reason i'm such a fan of magic spoon
is they allow me to enjoy the delicious
breakfast cereals i loved as a kid
without all the sugar and without the
unhealthy ingredients because magic
spoon makes breakfast cereal
that you really can't tell apart from
those tasty sugary cereals that we all
know
but each serving of magic spoon has no
sugar
three net carbs and 11 grams of protein
so it's perfect for someone on a low
carb
keto diet just anybody trying to eat
healthier and cut back on the sugar
you can choose from cocoa frosted fruity
cinnamon blueberry or peanut butter they
all taste amazing
and magic spoon now lets you create your
own customized variety pack
with the flavors you choose they really
do stand by their product and will
refund 100
of your money if you don't love it no
questions asked
go to magicspoon.compacman to build your
own
custom variety box today make sure to
use promo code pacman to get free
shipping
the link is right underneath this video
welcome back to the david pakman show
okay we are taking your calls for the
last
time before 2021
via discord davidpakman.com
discord let's go down to our
friendly neighbors to the south
in miami let's go to jacobo
from miami you are on the air
hi david oh my god wow i can't believe
you just
hi um i can't believe it i can't believe
that
so i'm i'm like 16 years old i'm from
miami i really like your show thank you
and uh i wanna know if you've said if
you've heard of the two thousand dollar
proposal that donald trump
has talked about yes i mean what's
we did a whole segment about it after
the um after
trump's weird four-minute speech what's
crazy is
i agree with trump two thousand dollars
would be a great number and reminder
i'm getting zero this is not for me i'm
not trying to get more money for myself
you understand kakovo
yeah good um the problem is
in the same speech trump said democrats
have prevented
anything from happening for months
democrats proposed two thousand dollars
six months ago and it went nowhere
because of republicans so
i agree with trump in that i like the
idea of two thousand dollars
which was also brought up by rokhana it
was also brought up by lots of other
people
but his four-minute speech was just
filled with lies
yeah yeah but um i also saw that like he
was mentioning that like
there should be uh stuff taken out of
the bill like so like
one of the things that i saw was 500
million dollars for israel or something
right so a couple different things first
of all
trump didn't mention israel trump
mentioned other countries
it's also not true that israel gets 500
million a lot of the countries that are
listed
um there's money allocated but it's it's
really money for american businesses
which a lot of people don't understand
and in addition to that that stuff isn't
in the covid bill
they did two bills together it was an
omnibus where they did
the spending bill to keep government
open and
they did the covet bill so it's not even
part of the same bill
and then like the third or fourth lie in
all of that
is trump criticized the money that some
countries
are getting not from the coveted bill
but from the spending bill
but trump requested that they get that
money months ago when he put together
his budget so it's like it's it's
it's five or six layers of deception
okay okay thank you thank you for
clearing
it up for me because like yeah i don't
know that i did i mean the lies are so
uh intertwined that i feel like it's
hard to even explain them all
yeah yeah because when he mentioned that
like i wouldn't think trump out of the
kindness of his heart
at the end of his presidency would give
every american all right two thousand
dollars
your instinct is correct your instinct
is correct
okay well thank you for taking my call
all right my pleasure there is
16 year old kakobo from miami i love it
um let's go next to i hope i'm
pronouncing this correctly is it
keon in queens or is it cayenne
hi it's cayenne cayenne all right very
all right so i
the first one was wrong but i got it
right on the second try right good job
i love your show and i have uh two
questions sure the first one uh
is about my prediction that uh
kamala harris will be running in 2024
and
probably nominating pete as her vp if
she decides that
his sexual orientation is not a risk
okay anyway
i think that um kamala's smart enough to
know that
uh her and biden cannot piss off the
progressives during their term and
otherwise the turnout in 2024 would be
you know if it's even just five percent
lower it could be detrimental to her
chances
so my instinct tells me that she would
push biden to do
a few more things that would make
progressives happy
so that she can like tout her
accomplishments during her presidential
run next time
so for example student loan forgiveness
would be one thing i would think that
she would be pushing
because i would see i don't see really
any negative to
biden you know increasing his uh
his his idea about you know i guess it's
ten thousand he wants to forgive now but
i don't see
any negative to him increasing that and
i just think that all the people that
would feel the relief
from that uh student loan forgiveness
would remember in 2024
and they would be more excited and have
a reason to actually come out to vote
for her
so so a few thoughts on that a few
thoughts on that um
a couple different things number one
remember um joe biden
can't get a lot of the things done i
don't actually think joe biden can do
even this student loan thing
if he doesn't get control of the senate
i just don't know i don't i don't
believe you can do that via executive
order
um and i don't see how he gets student
loan forgiveness done
without democrats controlling the senate
so it's very important to understand
that a lot of what you're talking about
is
is very nuanced and and uh important and
reasonable
but it's not simply up to oh does kamala
make sure joe biden throws some
bones to progressives to help him or her
in 2024
it's not just up to kamala convincing
joe biden there
there's realities here where without the
senate i don't see how any of this stuff
gets done
that's that's sort of like number one
number two
um i i do agree and you know there was
this earlier caller about how does the
how do progressives keep biden
accountable
if if democrats take the senate the way
they keep biden accountable is they
can't afford biden can't afford to lose
a single democratic vote in the senate
and that includes joe manchin
as much as it includes bernie sanders so
i think that's the answer to that piece
but
a lot of what you're saying is spot on
except it's not
up to kamala to convince joe because
it's legislatively difficult
without the senate
okay um thanks and
i have a second question
related to nina turner and she recently
announced uh
that she's running for ohio's 11th
district okay so
i feel like really excited about this
opportunity
having at least one more non-corrupt
person in in
congress and i feel the same way that i
felt when like jenk euger from tyt ran
for a seat in california
so when jank ran he announced his
candidacy i was like so hopeful and i
was almost certain that he would pull
out a win
given his national profile and support
from
across the nation and so as
like you may know and your viewers might
know that
jenk got trounced by the establishment
candidate in california and that really
surprised me
um so do you see any similarities with
uh
do you see any similarities with uh
nina's candidacy where it looks like she
would be a shoe-in with such a national
profile
and you know lots of grassroots uh
funding available to her
yep i really don't know to be perfectly
frank i don't know enough about that
district and i don't know enough about
the level to which
nina is known nationally like i know
about her and i know she appears on
national media with relative frequency
i i just don't have all the information
it might be a similar situation to jenk
or she might end up
you know wiping the floor in the 11th in
ohio i just don't know enough to be able
to say
about that district
okay well i'll just remain hopeful about
both issues with kamala
trying to push biden and nina hopefully
eaching out a win
and uh thank you for your time and i
enjoy your show thank you i appreciate
the call and
it seemed to to quote myself on previous
calls it seems like there's a lot going
on there so we're
i'm gonna let you i'm gonna let you go
but i really do appreciate the call
we are listening to the questions and
comments from folks
through discord davidpakman.com discord
speaking of ohio let's go to chris in
cincinnati chris you're on the air hi
thank you so much david um
so i just want to start a little bit
with a point in which we can agree on
um because i do kind of want to pressure
you a little bit on to
uh your thought on
the like aoc kind of controversy so uh
would you say that if your goal is
progressive
policy and a non-corrupt government
that uh pelosi probably wouldn't be a
good speaker of the house
um you're saying in in a vacuum i don't
think about it that way i don't think
pelosi um i'm not excited by nancy
pelosi
because i just don't find her to be
nearly
progressive enough so my preference
would be for a more progressive speaker
of the house
you know absent any other political
realities in a vacuum i'd rather someone
more progressive than nancy pelosi
right i think we can agree on that so i
think
politics 101 right you if you
don't agree with um a specific vote
right you don't agree with voting for
nancy pelosi for progressive policy then
you of course want to leverage your vote
right you'd want to
like get something out of voting for
pelosi whether that be
um a more progressive speaker of the
house which
is very unlikely or maybe getting some
political concessions
out of speaker pelosi correct those
would certainly be
things that one could tr seek yes right
so um what aoc has came out and said
what she would be trying to leverage for
her vote um the first thing she said was
a 15
minimum wage which is um like
incongruent with
like any sort of leverage because pelosi
and biden already said they're fighting
for that
so it doesn't really make sense and like
at best
it's just kind of misleading um and
gaslighting
uh okay but hold on a second can we can
i can we talk about that
when you say what aoc would want
in exchange for her vote for nancy would
be a 15
minimum wage the language is a little
bit confusing because
how would aoc voting for nancy pelosi
get a 15 minimum wage do you mean a vote
on a 15
minimum wage or what what specifically
that's that's a great that's a great
question so
um what aoc tweeted what she said in
response
um to how she's leveraging her vote for
nancy pelosi
it would be if i vote for nancy pelosi i
i have backdoor
kind of conversations with nancy pelosi
and make an agreement with her that
i will support her for a 15 minimum wage
if i support nancy pelosi
hold on a second i think you just said
something totally
i will support her for a 15 minimum wage
if i
i i think maybe you just misspoke can
you say that again aoc
said what exactly okay so
you can read the tweet that she said but
she's saying she's leveraging her vote
for speaker pelosi
in order to get a 15 minimum wage that
was directly her tweet
she did it in response to justin jackson
on twitter okay
i'm just saying i don't fully understand
what it means that she
she wants to getting a 15 minimum wage
is something that would have to pass the
house senate and be signed into law by
the president so i'm trying to
understand
i'm not saying you're giving me wrong
information i don't understand what it
means that
she's leveraging her vote for a 15
minimum wage because i just don't see
how nancy pelosi can make that happen is
she tech talking about
a vote on a 15 minimum wage
that's a great question i think like
these kinds of um the exact question
that you're bringing up
is kind of proof that what aoc is saying
in response to leveraging your vote
is kind of incongruent with not only the
way that this would
work properly but also like um
well that may be that maybe i guess it
depends on what aoc meant
i'm just not totally since i haven't
seen the tweet i
it's possible that it's clear what aoc
meant in the tweet but you but i'm not
hearing it yeah you i just don't well
maybe we shouldn't stick on that then
but i think the the point is still there
um
i i just find it interesting that uh
there was this whole debacle on
aoc's response to justin jackson
in part of this controversy and that was
really part of it
and um that's part of what though what
i'm trying to say what is the main
it was part of the disagreement about
forcing the vote
part of that disagreement saying aoc
wasn't left enough right
i mean i'm not going to say the
disagreement intentions for aoc right
listen
i don't know that i don't i wanna i want
to i want to have this conversation
i just am really struggling to know what
you're talking about when you say
that was part of the disagreement
what was part of which disagreement
between which parties there was a
disagreement
between people on the left like jimmy
dore who's
okay um there was a disagreement between
justin jackson
and brianna joy gray and secular talk
with uh aoc's policy making decisions
in how she's leveraging her vote okay
i'm first speaking pelosi
okay and this disagreement was on
twitter and
it came in aoc's response to justin
jackson
on twitter um and that's what really
sparked the controversy
of force the vote okay on top of jimmy
dore's
uh crazy outward rants about how
aoc is corrupt which i i don't support
right okay okay
so aoc said in response to justin
jackson
justin jackson saying on twitter that if
you don't
leverage your vote for medicare for all
which is like
force the vote then you are showing who
you truly are um
kind of saying like it's a litmus test
um and aoc responded to justin jackson
saying we are leveraging our vote and
we're doing it for a 15 minimum wage
okay who is justin who is justin jackson
sure he's
uh and he's an nfl football player
but on twitter he's a very active
leftist
um who frequently goes on like katie
halper's show
and um brianna joy grave uh bad faith
podcast
okay i don't know who so let me i'm
gonna try to bring this back maybe maybe
this is just not the right venue i don't
know who katie halper is i know brianna
joy gray was was bernie's
former former person we're like 10
layers deep in telephone was there a
specific
question for me on policy sure
yes okay on policy i
i would hope that you could um
just a little expand on what you think
would be the
best way to leverage your vote for
speaker pelosi
like maybe we could talk about that or
you could expand on
if we're going to vote for nancy pelosi
progressives i mean and you're going to
vote for someone that we don't clearly
agree with we
already said that what is the best way
we should leverage our vote for speaker
pelosi
okay i have a segment coming up about
this and i'm gonna lay out
in detail exactly the things that i
think would be more
uh more reasonable but
if we're gonna stay even in this
paradigm if
i were aoc and this doesn't mean this is
the right thing or the wrong thing
i would be more interesting more
interested
in uh pushing for something that uh
whole
if i'm gonna hold my vote hostage i
don't want to do it for a naughty nice
list on medicare for all
i would rather do it on standing firm on
twelve hundred or two thousand dollars
for people that need it just as one
example like i can come up with all
sorts of other examples
but i think there's actually a bigger
picture question here
about the types of things that members
of congress can try to get from the
speaker
that are beyond um symbolic votes to do
a naughty and like
nice list which includes things related
to
committee ships and it's a long list and
i'm going to have that clip very soon
all right thank you so much i really
appreciate it i'm sorry if it was
unclear but i love your show thank you
and says the leading remark brianna joy
gray had a great article
on like what this kind of effect would
have and also
david sirota on how to leverage your
vote properly but thank you so much
david
all right very good pleasure pleasure
pleasure hopefully we were able to uh
make
some um sense out of that eventually i
mean i think we got to
something interesting ultimately
let's go uh next to
um i guess this is is this ron from los
angeles
or it says a.a ron from los angeles is
it aaron from los angeles
it might not matter because i think this
person's self-muted and they're not
around last chance for ron
a ron or just aaron from los angeles
all right they're gone that's too bad
let's go next
to um let's go to enoch
from pittsburgh you're on the air
hello hi uh first of all uh thank you
for
uh having me pleasure um so i i just
have a question about the
congress vote that's coming up in i
believe it's january 6th
yes yeah uh so this is partially of my
ignorance because i'm still a little
like new to the politics and how all of
this work i'm honestly
you know just letting about the uh
congress vote to
um certify the electoral college
um and i i know it has been reported
that several senators and uh congressmen
were planning to uh vote against
the electoral college votes and i'm just
wondering if you think that it's still
possible
uh for uh trump and you know his uh
supporters
um in within the congress to try to uh
steal the election by
uh voting against the elect uh electoral
college uh results
no i don't think so um back in the year
remember that the role of the vice
president
is simply to count the votes not to
decide
whether votes are valid or anything like
that so i do expect that there will be
republican members of the house and
maybe even the senate who
when certain votes are counted will
stand up and present
an objection democrats tried this in the
year 2000
when the entire presidential election
between al gore and george w
bush depended on florida democrats stood
up and objected to the counting of the
florida
electoral votes and they were able to do
nothing to stop it
in this case it doesn't even come down
to one state it comes down to multiple
states
so i expect objections i don't expect
them to
to have any impact
okay thank you so much yeah i was just
asking because i guess the way
i understood it was uh if they uh vote
uh against uh those votes that uh i
guess they need to vote again but i
guess that was my
uh not understanding of the uh topic
yeah i don't think
i don't think it's gonna happen i
appreciate the call thank you very much
uh i don't i don't expect that to happen
but we'll be covering it live on january
6th that's for sure
all right i'm sorry i wasn't able to
talk to more folks today but we will
take
calls again in 2021 quick break
some audience questions coming up after
this short break
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
slash david pakman i've put the link
right underneath this video
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
all right let's get into um audience
questions for the week and the last
set of audience questions of 2020
very exciting okay first question david
we hear all the bluster from trump
special counsel martial law he won
lawsuits all of this other stuff is
trump genuinely going to try
to physically stay in the white house
after january 20th i think the answer is
still no
i think the answer is still no um i know
that there we reported on trump
floating or suggesting to some uh
some of his aides maybe i just won't
leave
sort of thing um i think that donald
trump
either already knows or will become
convinced
by the time january 20th rolls around
that it would be really really
embarrassing for himself to
you know have to be escorted out of the
white house or for reports to be that he
was refusing to leave or something like
that now
the truth is he probably has some
followers that are so sycophantic
that if trump tried it they would see it
as some kind of act of defiant heroism
rather than the corrosive act for the
country that it would be
but but i do believe that you know
trump's kids i think would all get it
like you can't physically try to stay it
would be humiliating to try to do it
um i don't think he's actually going to
try to do it now between now and then
he will continue in 61 he will continue
to tweet the things he's been tweeting
and look
at could could i maybe get this
overturned
in some way but even donald trump i am
sure recognizes
that just staying there absent
any court decision about you know not
accepting
results or these things are all going by
the wayside every time we reach
a new milestone in the process of
certifying and electors voting and all
of that
um i i think even trump recognizes
absent
something tangible to say look this
state has
flipped now or something i don't think
he's going to physically try to do it
now
i i admit that as someone who covers
this stuff
trump talks about ratings i can imagine
no greater ratings
than video of donald trump being
forcibly removed from the white house
but
i don't believe it will happen it would
be absolutely
terrible terrible for for the country i
believe really the milestone
date for trump will be january 6th um
i think on uh on on january 6th
mike pence is planning after the
official counting
of the electoral votes which have
already been cast remember january 6th
is just the formalization of
a joint session of the house and senate
counting those votes
mike pence is scheduled to within hours
leave the country and go on a trip to
i think it's poland and maybe uh uae i
don't remember exactly the countries
and i would not be surprised if trump is
even still in washington by then
there's rumors he he may be leaving
sooner um
for trump to completely disappear and
maybe even abandon the white house
i don't know there's the idea he'll stay
in the white house and then fly to a
rally on
inauguration day there's the idea he'll
never return from christmas
and just stay in florida there's the
idea that january 6th maybe when he
sort of formally gives it up and and we
stop hearing from him altogether
uh but i believe that he is not if if
the question is will trump
tr try and consider any mechanism or
manipulation
that might allow him to steal the
election the answer is of course yes and
he's thought of everything um lawsuits
of different kinds
trying to send different electors
convincing state legislatures and
governors to send different electors
that came and went
um seizing voting machines which is
some of his lawyers told him you can't
do martial law was reportedly float you
know all of
these different ideas he he's morally
willing to do any of it
but i do not believe he will physically
try to stay
uh in the oval office no next question
will republicans consider biden
illegitimate for four years
yeah i think that this is sort of a a
good question to be asking
the questions about will biden really be
sworn in seem like a waste of time
the questions about can donald trump
really
do this that that that that you know all
of these six seven eight different
things that he's
floated or others have floated as ways
to maybe steal the election we mentioned
some of them earlier
um lawsuits or seizing voting machines
having governors send different electors
all
that's none of that stuff is going to
happen i think the right question
is how corrosive is donald trump
insisting on this stuff to democracy
and in particular the way in which
donald trump maybe never conceding and
insisting he actually won
will affect the republican party
through joe biden's first two years and
four years
in the oval office now i think there's
two sides of it one is how will it
affect republican
officials and the second part is how
will it affect republican voters
let's do voters first because i think
that one's really easy uh
i think it's very clear at this point
that the combination of trump insisting
it was i mean just listen to the
voicemails i get people are convinced
trump insisting he really won
combined with newsmax and oan
and you know all of the different the
different hosts and
characters that have been insisting
trump actually won
that will leave a significant portion of
the
75 million who voted for trump believing
joe biden is an illegitimate president
for the duration of joe biden's
term there's no question about that one
is easy for me the voters
have been affected many believe trump
won etc
full stop the more interesting question
in terms of biden's governance because
biden can't really do anything about
millions of republicans thinking he's an
illegitimate president the real question
is about biden's governance
and will republican elected officials
republicans in the senate
republicans in the house of
representatives and republican governors
around the country
will they uh in some way
resist working with biden in any way
specifically by
by um failing him to recognize failing
to recognize him as a legitimate
president and i think it comes down to
how visible trump will be
after january 20th if we've already seen
more
and more republicans just say biden won
uh mitch mcconnell even congratulated
biden last week we covered that trump
was very
triggered by it if donald trump just
sort of evaporates politically
fades away on january 20th or before or
slightly after
i think you will see the vast majority
of republicans go back to dealing with
joe biden
the way they dealt with barack obama
which is there will be some who said
barack obama wasn't really born here and
isn't a legitimate president but for the
most part
they did the normal republican things
obstruct
pretend to be worried about the debt and
deficit call things government takeovers
anytime
the democratic president wants to do
something i think that's what you will
see
most republicans go back to now the
difference is
there are some really wacky uh congress
people elect
ready to be sworn in the house of
representatives um
in just days and i think that regardless
of what trump does
there's there's q on people who are
entering congress you know you have to
understand the the impact of that
i think they will continue to say
they're absolutely wacky stuff
uh for for the duration of their terms
and
hopefully they will be so ostracized by
left
and right that they will lose in 2022.
that would be the hope
it may not happen we may see more q anon
stuff in 2022. i just don't know yet
uh so that that's basically the lay of
the land i think that what trump has
done
has irreversibly um uh uh put
millions of his supporters in the
mindset that biden is not legitimate i'm
hearing from them in my voicemail every
single week
but the real question in terms of biden
for governance is how will republican
senators and members of congress
consider him and i think for the most
part they will see him as the legitimate
president
david we're getting close to those
georgia runoffs can joe biden
get anything done if democrats don't win
georgia
so this is a different version of
something we've we've been talking about
um if democrats are unable to win both
of those races making the senate a 50-50
tie
with kamala harris as the tie-breaking
vote i would be shocked
if anything substantial is done from a
legislative standpoint
mitch mcconnell will go back to the
obama playbook as i talked about in the
last segment
obstruct everything offer no
bipartisanship period uh in addition to
that
um even with winning the runoffs there
are lots of issues that are going to be
a fight
uh when you consider i know the the it's
almost cliche to say but
uh joe manchin from west virginia is the
most right-wing
democratic senator there are lots of
biden ideas that i have a hard time
imagining
joe manchin goes for now maybe you can
find a republican or two
to go for them even if joe manchin
doesn't but the next two years will be a
very
big uphill battle for joe biden
legislatively
regardless of what happens in in uh
january in georgia
without those wins nothing gets done
and and joe biden will essentially have
to govern by
pyrrhic compromise where you have to
give up so much in order to get
republicans to
to work with you that if there's a
question as to whether it's even a
worthwhile exchange and by executive
order
fortunately biden can get a lot of
things done by executive order
and my hope is that what biden can't do
legislatively in these first two years
uh he can do via building goodwill and
and sort of reestablishing the us as
respectable globally
which our global reputation has been in
the toilet thanks to donald trump
um but but then you know the real the
complicated part the part where it gets
tough
is even with both senate seats
um what what of the big things
can you actually get done um
for some for really major things
you also need a super majority which
democrats with 50 50 and kamala harris
as the tiebreaker
uh aren't aren't going to have they'll
be able to do the budget bill that only
needs 50 votes
they can put some extras in it and and
see what else they can get done that way
they will be able to confirm supreme
court justices if joe biden
indeed gets to nominate anybody and you
know maybe you can do some
infrastructure
um maybe you can do it's just health
climate and tax reform seem really
really tough
um and it's it's going to be an uphill
battle so that's that's my perspective
at this point and then of course there's
this idea of
do they do they do away with the
filibuster um
divergent opinions on the left about
that let's just wait and see what
happens january 5th in georgia before we
have that conversation because i think
that let's not even waste our breath
on that issue until we know what's going
to happen
in the state of georgia we have a great
bonus show for you today and remember we
are off next week
no new shows next week everybody relax
the show's not canceled
just an end of the year break so bonus
show coming up right after this become a
member at joinpakman.com
to get instant access and then nothing
next week
and then back with you on monday january
4th 2021
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
nebia is a revolutionary shower head
that saves you money by using
45 percent less water but with a stream
of water that's way more powerful
than what you get with other shower
heads to get 15
off go to nebia.com pacman and use the
code
pacman magic spoon is the cereal that
tastes
exactly like the delicious cereals from
your childhood except it has no sugar
tons of protein and only three net carbs
so it's perfect for a keto diet
to get free shipping go to
magicspoon.com
pacman and use the code pacman blinkist
is the app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person by letting you read
or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
david pakman